yes
right
hell's wrong with you man what's going
on stop like a [ __ ] what's going on man
ah
[Music]
[Music]
god damn it what you let the console you
did you what no maybe I don't
maybe everybody goes to close the closet
first baby put myself that book that
bacon [ __ ] oh so you tell me that you're
perfect and you don't make mistakes you
put the new batteries in the nightlight
yeah you sure
I just said yeah yeah but you sound a
serve-yourself it's making me nervous
look if I didn't put batteries in the
goddamn things you chop my dick off all
right
David
David that's right you are two clicks
away but be Africans as [ __ ] with yep
you know say yeah your peanut shake
[ __ ] yeah yeah called you a [ __ ] yeah
and I said you got big titties like one
double D's
matter of fact you could be a stunt
double just go like this right now for
you come right back up your [ __ ] get it
[ __ ] yeah you don't talk about my Teddy
stop yeah you know [ __ ] [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
oh I close the top [ __ ] I'm
about to walk there turn off that light
and kill us both you yeah I will do that
I'm crazy
you won't you won't [ __ ] hands now
well you scared dog mmm don't check down
foot work dot I'm not done [ __ ]
you look like a deaf mute
you do I'll do it right now - I'll do it
right now
go ahead make my day
do we
[Music]
[Music]
Hey please wasn't gonna do [ __ ] [ __ ]
y'all put your hands on me you lucky I'm
afraid of the talk
[Music]